president biden facing some big
challenges on his first
trip overseas he is set to meet with
european allies at the g7 about ways to
counter threats from china
and russia that's the easy part biden
will then meet face to face with
vladimir putin
and he is talking tough i'm heading to
the g7
then to the nato ministerial and then to
meet with mr putin
to let him know what i want him to know
we're going to make it clear that the
united states is
back been clear the united states will
respond
in a robust and meaningful way when the
russian government engages in harmful
activities
you know katie this idea that america is
back i don't know if he understands what
had been going on when
president trump was president and the
foreign policy successes
and how our adversaries viewed him i
mean that's pretty
clueless well i'm sure vladimir putin is
very worried about his upcoming meeting
with president biden but i do
hope that it is successful and it goes
well but this idea that
america is back so president trump is
criticized all the time for not talking
tough enough on russia but behind the
scenes they were doing a bunch of
sanctions they were
you know taking away their ability to
give energy to western europe they were
they
actually put teeth into what they were
doing joe biden just allowed russia to
finish the nordstrom 2 pipeline which
gives them control over europe
and there's been this big question about
nato and the role of nato for years now
because
nato essentially was formed to combat
russia
but if we're going to allow russia to
control europe through energy
or we're not going to force all these
nato allies to pay their
two percent which by the way is a legal
agreement that they made to contribute
to this alliance that we have
then what really is the the point of
nato and it being strong i mean trump
was
tough on nato but it was a tough love he
was saying look if you really want to
combat russia
and carry out the mission of nato then
we all got to be in this together
and pay our fair share so i don't see
that coming from biden right now but
maybe
he has a different thing to say out of
the end you know dana the fact is as
long as
joe doesn't eat a live dog on tv the
press is going to call this a raving
success
oh and there's no doubt because this is
the first yeah so all of that headlines
america is back they're happier look oh
everyone's smiling
yes oh look now and you know what the
biggest issue for especially for the
media
and a lot of europeans it's climate well
um remember like pulling out of the
paris climate accords that was the thing
that
really made everybody mad during the
trump administration so tone and
demeanor of course will be different but
for uh getting good media coverage on
the first part of this trip will be a
layup yeah you know geraldo i think it
was a myth that they
that you know the media obviously was a
lie that trump didn't get along with
these leaders
whenever trump showed up in these
foreign countries
people were excited and they knew where
he was coming from
they don't know where president biden's
coming from right he's got no vision
well it's worse than that greg remember
crimea
fell to putin during the obama
administration
and the democrats have been very squishy
it seems to me katie's right about nato
particularly
as a war correspondent over all these
decades one thing that always irked me
was how little the presence was of our
european allies
you know two percent of their gross
actual products should be spent on their
own defense
and yet we're paying for the bases in
germany we're paying for the bases
everywhere
and uh i don't trust uh a democratic
regime i liked
seeing trump and putin together they
seemed
maybe it's just optics they seemed equal
to me they didn't
like trump seemed uh he's the boisterous
bullying
braggart and so is putin and uh you know
they were evenly matched yeah you know
jesse uh putin's got to be disappointed
because he can't blackmail
president biden because everything is
out there with hunter
it's like it's like you can't find any
there's no pee tape
right because hunter's scott we'll be
talking about the laptop from hell in
the next block i think
here's what i would do if i were
president biden in the middle of the
meeting with putin
i would have our defense department
launch a cyber attack against their oil
company in the middle of the meeting
and then after the meeting was over i
would announce that i was going to
double the military aid package to
ukraine
then when i'm talking to the eu guys i
would say
guys we are going to boycott the
olympics in china that would humiliate
the chinese it would bring the supply
chains out of there and it would give us
the moral high ground
and then i would demand reparations from
china if they couldn't prove that it
wasn't from the lab
and then i would say you guys
complaining about all the migrants
coming from the middle east and north
africa
not my problem anymore i'm out of the
middle east you guys police your own
neighborhood
and then with the tariffs here's what
game i would play there
i'd say to cocaine mitch i'd say mitch
you want those tariffs dropped down from
that whiskey in kentucky
i'll get the europeans to drop that down
if you meet me halfway in infrastructure
i'd do the same thing with lindsey
graham boeing's in south carolina
i'd say i'd dial back this aircraft
trade war a little bit
if you meet me halfway on infrastructure
and then with germany
i'd keep the steel tariffs because you
know what screw them they're buying gas
from russia
and then anything else i wanted arctic
security
i don't know orange juice tariffs down
i'd use vaccine diplomacy
the one thing i wouldn't do though i
wouldn't make a
mistake in front of the queen jesse that
you can't do if you're going to be
president how many scoops of ice cream
will you have
that's what we all know i think you just
tried to save the world
and then you get up and then you leave a
copy of your book how i saved the world
in front of each world leader
you should say that after every
commentary love that on an ipod for the
queen
yeah break after here it was solved like
that though it was really
impressive there you go coming up hey
sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else